the infamous Comey memos are out and you
know who's happy about it
president Trump won memo reveals the
president actually early on endorsed the
idea of looking into any possible
wrongdoing by people related to his
campaign Comey wrote mr. Trump told him
quote if there was some satellite note I
took this to mean some associate of his
or of his campaign it did something it
would be good to find that out but that
he hadn't done anything and hoped I
would find a way to get out that we were
not investigating him the president says
the notes show clearly there was a no
collusion ad no obstruction and that the
FBI director leaked classified
information Comey claimed in another
passage she doesn't do sneaky things he
doesn't leak or do weasel moves he went
on to leak his memo and admits he did it
I know when I created some of them they
were classified but I don't know how
many of that group be testifying that
you did this to try to force the
creation of a special counsel why why
would a special counsel be needed why
would the Department of Justice and FBI
not be able to continue to do the job
because I thought that the department
has currently supervised would not be
aggressive enough to go serve process to
get the tapes since Jeff sessions is too
weak well he had recused himself
so rod Rosen Stein was a new Deputy
Attorney General who I didn't have
confidence and given what I'd seen
around my firing and so I thought
something has to be done because there
were lots of discussions in public then
about appointing a special prosecutor
Fox News has confirmed that the watchdog
at the Department of Justice is now
investigating commis handling of the
memos whether classified information was
given to unauthorized outside sources so
Kimberly we're laughing about the line
weasel move but it's not funny because I
don't know if you saw Hannity last night
I did because I watch it almost every
night and they had a rundown of some of
the violations that he may be looking at
for leaking classified information and a
lot of it looks pretty serious yeah for
sure and here's what's so interesting
and I think it's very compelling is so
there's no proof of a you know collusion
or obstruction of justice and let me
tell you something he just completely
torpedoed Muller so the president should
send him a little thank-you note thanks
weasel moves
because this is great all you have to do
is like read from the memos to show that
beyond a reasonable doubt beyond any
doubt that the president didn't direct
anybody in terms of you know any
collusion or try to obstruct anything
whatsoever it really helps the president
that's why the president today said I
was vit you know vindicated yeah because
this helped his side so what call me is
thinking I don't know he completely
compromised anything that Muller could
have tried to be cooking up because now
it's gonna be fraught with
inconsistencies and fraught with
problems in terms of other witnesses
that he might be trying to call or bring
forward all of the prior inconsistent
statements the statements that Comey is
made on the book this book tour the
statements in the book the statements
prior to the release of the book the
complications with Loretta Lynch it's
just a big stirred up pot of doubt and
mass courtesy of the former head of the
FBI right Comey is collapsing Greg and
on a number of levels as kg says one of
the things he says he doesn't leak in
any leaks and then he actually went on
to say that McCabe total professional
great guy you can trust him you know he
doesn't leak either and then McCabe
leaks and then lies about it so the top
two guys at the FBI not looking too good
yeah you know what I feel really bad for
I feel bad for the resistance oh I do I
do because it you know and keep
expecting a horse for Christmas but they
get a hamster and in this case this is a
dead hamster I mean they have been the
left hasn't been this disappointed since
the Berlin Wall fell it's as if you know
what it is this it's as if they're
intense obsession to unseat a president
is creating like a karmic poltergeist do
you know what I mean it's like it's like
every time they think they're gonna get
a smoking gun they get a flaming bag of
dog poo on their porch and they step
right into it
so here's I have a suggestion or an
exercise for every person in the media
primarily those on CNN and MSNBC over
the weekend over the weekend take 10
minutes to yourself and try to answer
yourself this one question one question
what is the endgame to all of this
coverage about Comey about store me
about collusion is it justice for an
adult film star is
is it trying to uncover some secret
conspiracy that you've been working on
for two years almost but haven't found a
thing or are you just trying to get rid
of a president right because if that's
the case if that's the case you're
actually hurting the country and you're
hurting everybody in actually in the
country over a personal vendetta
political yeah it is and because they
have been emotionally triggered by an
election because I don't think I
honestly don't think when people are
reporting on this stuff they actually
ask what's the endgame what do I want
out of this other than ten minutes of
good ratings it's a great point because
I was going to bring this up the
Democratic National Committee is now
suing yeah Trump campaign Jared Kushner
Don jr. Russia itself and WikiLeaks for
interfering and making Hillary lose what
kind of frivolous lawsuit is this well
it's the last dying breath of the
resistance because they're basically
blaming Trump for everything that they
actually did which was collude with the
Russians come up with this dossier that
was paid for by Cruz go back to call me
for saying cuz this really makes me mad
he didn't just say I'm not a leaker and
then we find out any leaks he said I'm
not a weasel I'm a straight shooter he's
in the office with the President of the
United States
what would a straight shooters say when
he brings up the dossier he would say
hey there's this dossier about you and
prostitutes in Moscow and by the way
it's been a straight shooter would say
it's been paid for by Hillary Clinton
and the DNC and he did it he's not a
straight shooter to the end game the end
game is to not just potentially impeach
the president which is what they really
want but ultimately also to dispirit
trump voters it is to make us feel those
of us who voted for him and who wanted
this agenda to go forward to dispirit us
to pull the poll numbers town I look at
the president's poll numbers I can't
believe how high they are considering
how much has been thrown at him on it's
unbelievable Rasmussen hasn't been about
90 last time we checked this probably up
to 99 very good question about the DNC I
think this is one of the most bonehead
moves I've seen in a long time because
do they not understand that there's
reciprocal discovery on both sides
this is just gonna be just a treasure
trove of information coming forward to
the other side so instead of always I'm
an investigative special counsel you
this and that
oh yeah show me what you have yeah show
me the share document GPS payments let's
see it all salutely and they thought
this might be a good idea cuz because
they're muddy the waters and dust it up
a little bit before the midterm
elections create some problems for the
Republicans but instead they made a
whole bunch of problems for themselves
good job okay so a resident Democrat
here to defend everything admitting that
he did not tell Donald Trump that
Hillary paid for the dossier when he
briefed him on it and also that he
doesn't even really know if the dossier
is legitimate or not I I think he says
something like it's unlikely but
possible the dirt on Trump let's hear
what he said right what you asked me
about now is why did I say what I said
when people asked me whether I thought
it was possible that the Russians had
derogatory information on President
Trump I think it's unlikely but I think
it's possible so he put something that
he considered unlikely forward to a
judge to get a warrant to spy on the
Trump campaign that's not good so what's
interesting in the Comey memos is when
he talked about the dossier writ large
not just the very salacious details the
president seems very focused on about
the hotel room in Moscow but in the
Comey memos he briefs the president that
the intelligence community has
corroborated and confirmed parts of the
dossier which parts were there if that's
not he does not detail that in the Comey
memo I would like to know that then
let's find out but he makes clear that
there is intelligence to back up other
pieces of the dossier so it is not
unsubstantiated well we know that they
substantiate that there is a place
called Moscow this week that Michael
Cohen may have actually been in Prague
so I think we need to be careful you
don't like that trunk
do you Murray believe that Trump
actually colluded with the Russians with
this campaign you actually believe that
I believe that members of close to the
Russian government including former and
current intelligence officials reached
out to the Trump campaign and offered
help we know that that's been publicly
discussed and
believe that the Trump campaign was
willing to work with them whether it was
to release Hillary's emails welcome to
that help what Donald Trump newer did I
don't know that's what Bob Muller is
looking into we know they were members
of the campaign willing to meet with
Russians and discuss Hillary's emails
that's if that's a fact that's been
reported I don't know what answers two
three four five are that's what Muller
is looking into right now and call me is
only a small part of that all right and
the larger investigation Comey is not
the end-all be-all here let's stick to
the facts there's been no contact that
shows there was any sort of collusion
whatsoever whatsoever about working
together I don't know anything about
discussions Hillary actually paid for
Russian dirt that was used up on the
Trump campaign name on either one I call
a dork at the Washington Examiner had a
great piece today oh my gosh when he
said imagine that you are you know
you're the FBI director your first
meeting with the president elect Donald
Trump and you go in and you go I have
this salacious information on you Donald
Trump probably thought he was being
blackmailed he actually said that to a
reporter and do you think that that's a
good idea to lead with this dirty
dossier in your first meeting with the
president maybe that's why President
Trump was saying maybe we need a little
loyalty here because he felt like he
couldn't trust James Comey we're now
finding out here from the the memo that
it was pressure from CNN let's show it
on the screen here that led to James
Comey briefing the president
I said media like CNN had them and we're
looking for a news hook
I explained again why I had thought it
was important that he know about it I
also explained that one of the reasons
we told him was at the media CNN in
particular was telling us they were
about to run with it and then the story
leaks to CNN a few hours later I mean I
understand why the president didn't
trust I look as they come shady James
follow the snail trail I mean this one
was laid out for you how I mean
unbelievable so he probably should have
run to a nice like introductory meeting
talk to the president because it's very
off-putting if I'm saying we
second okay why are you bringing this up
to me and to call me if I'm listening
somebody say this I'm thinking he's
trying to catch him catch him off-guard
come in and say something like that like
he's looking to try to hook him before
he even just you know has exchanges
pleasantries hugs a job he's right away
going after him that shows the intended
purpose the specific intent and whose
team he was playing for in fact his
whole team family was in unison against
the president getting the march on doing
everything from like you know day one he
was in the back booth and why does CNN
have it what is going if there's the
delusion you don't have to look to
Russia to find out I think I mean if
there was some kind of strategy involved
here that they needed a legitimate angle
beyond just the dossier to report on it
right because it was it was frivolous
and unproven the legitimate angle was
the briefing precisely
so that's though commis briefing was
kind of like a Trojan horse for actually
just wanting to talk about the dossier
it's like saying I'm going out for a
walk when you're actually going to get
cigarettes and what do we call that
weasel move